I understand that some of Jude behaviors  would be upsetting but I urge you to  find a place where he feels safe I think  it would be good for him good for all of  us  oh my goodness take it out I must be the  very nice dude how is this film  different from anything that you've done  before well every film is unique because  it's a different character and you're at  a different place in your creative life  I felt like what drew me to this movie  was the people involved and also this  this character Liza who is very  vulnerable and very protective and in a  place where she's open to being sort of  haunted and I I felt like William Brent  Belle is such a such a big wonderful at  visuals and he was great to work with  and I from what I've seen I'm really  proud of the movie and I think that  people seem to be really liking horror  movies again so it's nice to be a part  of something that hopefully people will  go and see  you